استخدم الجيش الاسرائيلي لاول مره منذ
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه مروحيات
اباتشي لقصف مواقع داخل مخيم جنين ضمن
عمليات اقتحام اسفرت عن استشهاد خمسه وجرح
عشرات الفلسطينيين واكدت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه انها اصابت جنودا اسرائيليين
واعطبت اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه وسط دعوات
داخل حكومه نتنياهو لتصعيد عمليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نقرا تطور اداء
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في التصدي لاقتحامات
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدن ومخيمات
الضفه الغربيه واستخدام المقاومين عبوات
ناسفه في تفجير اليات اسرائيليه اسفرت عن
اصابه سبعه جنود كيف ستنعكس هذه التطورات
على المشهد الفلسطيني وعلى المشهد الداخلي
باسرائيل على المستويين السياسي والامني
وما مدى تاثيرها على المواقف الامريكيه
ورؤيه واشنطن لمستقبل الصراع وعمليه
السلام في المنطقه
المحتمله لمالات الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه
بعد تصاعد لهجه التحريض المباشر من قبل
وزراء يمينيين متطرفين بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه بشن عمليه عسكريه واسعه في
الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
فرض التصعيد الاسرائيلي الجديد في الضفه
الغربيه نفسه محطه جديره بالتامل في سياق
عمليه الاقتحام التي درج جيش الاحتلال على
شنها بين حين واخر في الضفه الغربيه
وغيرها بالنظر الى ما اسفرت عنه سرايا
القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه
قالت ان المواجهه على ارض جنين تثبت تجذر
المقاومه التي لقنت العدو درسا جديدا حركه
حماس ثمنت رد المقاومه الفلسطينيه على
الاقتحامات العسكريه الاسرائيليه مشيره
الى ان الكمين الذي نصبه المقاومون للقوات
الاسرائيليه في جنين جاء محكما ومفاجئا
لها في المقابل تعالت الاصوات داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه داعيه للاستمرار في
العمليات العسكريه وتوسيعها نتنياهو اكد
ان قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي مصممه على ضرب
ما وصفه بالارهاب في كل مكان وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
عزف على نفس الوتر قائلا ان الوقت حان لشن
عمليه عسكريه واسعه في الضفه الغربيه
تتضمن استخدام القوات الجويه والمدرعه في
الاثناء دعت السلطه الفلسطينيه الاداره
الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي الى التدخل
لوقف معاته بالجنون الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وسينضم الينا
لاحقا من فرجينيا السفير توماس
في اسرائيل سنبدا معك مرحبا بك دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي كيف تابعت وقيمت ما حدث
اليوم في جنين
اعتقد اولا ان الشعب الفلسطيني باسره يشعر
بالفخر والاعتزاز اليوم لاداء المقاومه
الباسل والبطولي في مواجهه هذه الهجمه
الفاشيه التي جهشنها جيش الاحتلال والذي
لم يتورع عن استخدام طائرات اف 16 وطائرات
اباتشي لاول مره منذ الانتفاضه الثانيه ضد
مقاومين لا يملكون اسلحه بسيطه الذي
رايناه فعلا بطوله وبساله غير مسبوقه
عندما تم اعطاب تدمير سبع اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه واصابه ثمن جنود اسرائيليين
وبالاضافه الى ذلك
اصابه حتى طائره الاباتشي باعتراف الجيش
الاسرائيلي المهم ان العمليه الاسرائيليه
التي شنت اليوم اظهرت ارتباك وفشل للجيش
الاسرائيلي فشله الاستخبارات اولا فشل
العمليات ثانيا وحاله الارتباك التي ظهرت
قبل قليل في اعتداء وحشي اخر قام به جيش
الاحتلال على سياره مدنيه
في غرب جنين واثناء هذا الاعتداء قاموا
باطلاق الرصاص على انفسهم فاصابوا جنديين
بانفسهم فبالتالي الذين نراه هو حاله فشل
وارتباك والذي نراه ايضا مقاومه فلسطينيات
مصممه على التصدي لكل عمليات الاعتقال
التي يقوم بها جيش الاحتلال ولكل عمليات
الاقتحام اليوم لا يستطيع جيش الاحتلال ان
يدخل اي مدينه او قريه في فلسطين دون ان
يجابه بمقاومه باي شكل
تجاره اليوم في جنين وكانت نوعيه شهدت
تطورا في اداء المقاومين الفلسطينيين ما
الرساله التي ارسلتها باعتقادك
الرساله بسيطه وواضحه لا يمكن لجيش
الاحتلال ان يقتل الفلسطينيين ويعتدي
عليهم ويدمر ممتلكاتهم دون ان يدفع ثمنا
هناك ثمن للجرائم الاسرائيليه التي ترتكب
والذي جرى اليوم يضغط على اسرائيل في نقاط
الضعف الثلاثه التي لديها
حساسيتها الشديده للخسائر البشريه
حساسيتها الخسائر الاقتصاديه
وحساسيتها للخسائر المعنويه والاخلاقيه
واليوم هي جيش الاحتلال تلقى ضربه معنويه
كبيره وخاصه ان هذه الضربه جاءت بعد
الاعلان الفاشي امس عن نيه حكومه اسرائيل
توسيع المستوطنات والمستعمرات وتسليمي
قرارات انشائها لهذا الفاشي المستوطن
سموتريتش وعمليا الاعلان كان يعني ضم
اعلان عن نيه ضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه
الرد تلقوه اليوم في جنين بان الفلسطيني
لن يقبل ولن ينكسر امام هذا الضغط
الاسرائيلي والمقاومه اكبر واقوى من ان
تستطيع اسرائيل بقمعها ان تكسرها طيب ولكن
الدكتور مصطفى يعني بالحديث عن الثمن كيف
يمكن
تقييم الثمن ما هو الحساب وما هو باي
طريقه نحسب هذا الثمن الذي تكبده اليوم
جيش الاحتلال وماليه الحساب لان اذا نظرنا
الى ما حدث يعني نحن نتحدث عن اعطاب اليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه
سقوط سبعه جرحى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولكن بالمقابل هناك خمسه شهداء فلسطينيين
واكثر من 90 جريحا
هناك
166 وقد يصل العدد الى 170 شهيد منذ بدايه
هذا العام
والاصابات الثمانيه التي وقعت اليوم في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي تعني ماذا في
الماضي كان هناك شهداء ولم يكن هناك ثمان
اسرائيلي يدفع
التطور الذي يحدث الان ان هناك ثمن
الجرائم التي ترتكب ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
دائما هناك شهداء ودائما هناك اعتداءات
ودائما هناك اعتقالات ولكن الذي يحدث
التغير الذي يحدث ان هناك ثمن للجرائم
التي ترتكب ضد الشعب الفلسطيني طيب دكتور
مصطفى الان الفصائل الفلسطينيه تتوعد
جيش الاحتلال بانه سيتم اللجوء الى اساليب
جديده الى
وسائل ستفاجئ جيش الاحتلال كما ورد في
بيان سرايا القدس
ماذا ننتظر
انا اعتقد ان اكثر ما سيفاجئ الاحتلال ليس
فقط الامور التقنيه التي راينا نموذجا لها
اليوم بهذه العبوات التي استخدمت بكثافه
وبجراه يعني هناك جراه وشجاعه هائله رغم
ان معظم الشهداء الذين استشهدوا اليوم من
الجانب الفلسطيني واصيبهم من المدنيين
العزه لكن ما رايناه هو جراه هائله من قبل
هؤلاء المقاومين في التصدي لهذا الجيش
المدجج بالسلاح ولكن المفاجاه التي قد
تنتظر الاسرائيليين بعد ان اعلنوا نواياهم
القبيحه بضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه واعلنوا
عمليا للفلسطينيين انه لا حل وسط معهم هو
ان الضفه الغربيه باسرها ستشهد انتفاضه
شعبيه شامله ردا على ما يقوم به هذا
المحتل وان الفلسطينيين يدركون اليوم انه
لا سبيل امامهم لردع هذه الجرائم ولردع
الاستعمار الاستيطاني ولردع ايضا
المستوطنين الارهابيين الذين يمارسوا
الاره ضد الفلسطينيين في كل مكان لا رد
عليهم الا بالمقاومه والكفاح على الارض
ولكن هذا الكلام عن انتفاضه شامله عن تحرك
موسع اكثر من جانب الفلسطينيين يتم الحديث
عنه منذ اشهر ومع ذلك لم نراه على الارض
بهذا الشكل وبهذه الطريقه بالمقارنه مع ما
حدث في الانتفاضه مثلا الثانيه هل هذا ما
يجرا باعتقادك الاحتلال على القيام
بالمزيد
الواقع انه ما نشهده هو انتفاضه من نوع
جديد وانا اتحدث عن ذلك مش منذ اشهر منذ
سنوات الواقع الذي تعيشه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله هو نوع من الانتفاضه
التي تجري على شكل موجات متلاحقه ومتتاليه
سواء تلك الهبه الرائعه التي جرت عام 2017
في القدس او عام 2021 او التصدي الباسل في
قطاع غزه لكن الامر الاساسي هنا انه الشعب
الفلسطيني يدرك انه لا خيار امامه سوى
المقاومه والكفاح والنضال وما ينقصنا هو
وحده كل المكونات ما ينقصنا هو ان تكون
هناك الان قياده وطنيه فلسطينيه موحده على
رؤيا واستراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه مقاومه
تتصدى لهذا الاحتلال وتتصدى لجرائمه دعيني
اشير الى انه جيش الاحتلال اليوم شن حربا
فعليا على منطقه مدنيه وشن حربا على منطقه
تقع تحت احتلا هذا لم يجري لم يجري الا من
قبل الفاشيين في التاريخ البشري وبالتالي
ما يقومون به وتجرؤهم هو سبب الرئيسي
الصمت المشين الدولي على الجرائم
الاسرائيليه وازدواجيه المعايير التي
تستخدم في التعامل مع الفلسطينيين وبصراحه
اكثر ضعف الرد الفعل العربي اليوم انا
برايي بعد ان اقدمت اسرائيل على اعلان
الضم والتهويد للضفه الغربيه بكاملها من
خلال الاستعمار الاستيطاني وبعد هذه
الهجمات والتهديد الان بهجمه شرسه جديده
على الشمال في فلسطين اليوم الرد العربي
يجب ان يكون مقاطعه شامله لهذه الحكومه
الفاشيه عندما يزور دول العالم لا احد
يلتقي به كذلك بنجبير اليوم يجب ان تكون
مقاطعه لكل الحكومه الفاشيه التي يتراسها
نتنياهو وفيها هؤلاء الفاشين المجرمين
وهذا سيساهم
الى الموقف السياسي ولكن بما انك ذكرت ان
الاحتلال كما قلت شن حربا على المنطقه
مدنيه اريد ان اتوقف معك ايضا عند الحرب
التي شنت في نفس الاطار على الصحافيين
الذين كانوا متواجدين في المنطقه
وتعلم يعني فكرنا اليوم اخذنا من جديد الى
ما الى الى اغتيال زميله شيرين ابو عاقله
في جنين تحديدا بالنظر الى ان جيش
الاحتلال كان يتعامل بوحشيه شديده مع
الصحفيين المتواجدين في المنطقه
طبعا واحد الصحفيين يصيب بالرصاص وهذا
اضافه جديده للعمليات الاعتداء التي يقوم
بها الاحتلال ودعيني اذكر ان الشهيده
شيرين ابو عقلي كانت الشهيده رقم 52 من
بين الصحفيين الفلسطينيين الذين اغتالهم
جيش الاحتلال خلال عشر سنوات الماضيه ايضا
اليوم اعتدوا على فرق الاسعاف اعتدوا على
سيارات الاسعاف التابعه للهلال الاحمر
ولجمعيه الاغاثه الطبيه الفلسطينيه
ومنعوهم من الوصول الى الجرحى والمصابين
في الوقت المناسب وهذا ايضا يتكرر كل يوم
وفي كل مواجهه تجري مع الاحتلال ابقى معي
دكتور مصطفى انضم الينا الان عبر الهاتف
من فرجينيا السفير توماس السفير الامريكي
السابق في اسرائيل
كيف راقبت ما حدث اليوم في جنين
انما نشهده في جنين
وفي باقي الاراضي المحتله هو ان الوضع
يتردى ويزداد سوءا المزيد من المواجهات
المزيد من النزاعات
وهذا مقلق بالنسبه الينا جميعا في الوقت
المتحده لا نزال منشغلين وقليقين بشان
موضوع ايجاد حل هذه المشكله نحن فعلا
ناسف اسفا شديدا لرؤيه هذا الحال يبتعد
اكثر فاكثر
لا سيما ان العنف
هذا العنف المنظم الذي يحصل الان هو وبطرق
مختلفه يزيد الوضع رديا
وهذا سوف يكون
سوف يقود اي احتمال نجاح في ايجاد حل
عمليا سعاده السفير هذا الاعراب عن القلق
من جانب الاداره الامريكيه وايضا
من جانب المجتمع الدولي ليس جديدا ولكن هل
هذه الطريقه المثلى للتعامل مع الاوضاع
خصوصا ان الوضع يزداد سوءا بوجود هذه
الحكومه من اليمينيين المتطرفين
طبعا لا طبعا لا وانا اعتقد ان فكره تردي
الوضع وزيادته سوءا هي فعلا فكره صريحه
تعبر عن حقيقه الوضع اعتقد ان الحكومه
الامريكيه صارت تقلل من حتى اعتذارها
واسفها تجاهها الفلسطينيين وكيفيه
معاملاتهم ويتعرضون له
ويبدو ان هناك دائما عراقيل مستمره لاي
نقاش لاي حوار
بالنسبه الى اي جهود لدفع
او للمضي قدما في ايجاد حل في ايجاد دوله
للفلسطينيين لمعاملاتهم طريقه عادله
ومنصفه لجميع من هم في هذه المنطقه وهذا
امر قد رغبت منطقه فيه منذ فتره طويله
وانا شاركت في هذا
في نفس الاطار الذي تتحدث به الجانب
الفلسطيني يعتبر انه في صلب هذا الموضوع
في صلب هذه المشكله التقاعس الامريكي عن
الضغط عن السلطه عن عن الضغط عن السلطات
الاسرائيليه
هذا صحيح برايه اعتقد انه على مر سنوات
تعددت سبل وطرق التعامل مع هذه المشكله
ولكن لم يكن اي من هذه الطرق نافعه ليس
هناك اي حل من اجل التخفيف في عن الضغط
الذي يتعرض له الفلسطينيون وهذا ما عزز
تردي الوضع في الوقت نفسه فان عناصر الضغط
الاخرى
التي يمكن تفعيلها لايجاد حل يبدو انه يتم
تجاهلها
اذا الوضع لا يتيح احقاق الحق
وتنفيذ العداله وبشكل يكون منصفا
لطرفين للاسف
اعمال العنف ايضا تزيد الوضع سوءا ونحن
نرى ذلك على اساس يومي وهي ايضا لا تاتي
باي جواب لاي سؤال
الناس يختارون احبائهم بسبب العنف وطبعا
سوف يشعرون باللوعه
وكذلك
ما يزيد وضع سوءا هو انه لا حل ابقى معي
سعاده السفير ودكتور مصطفى البرغوثي في
المواقف الدوليه من التطورات في الضفه
الغربيه وما يجري فيها من تصعيد اسرائيلي
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
قال ان الصعيد في جنين يهدد بادخال
المنطقه في ازمه خطيره من جانبه اعرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه ازال الاحداث
الاخيره في جنين قائلا في بيان له انه يجب
ان تكون العمليات العسكريه متناسبه
ومتوافقه مع القانون الدولي الانساني
دكتور مصطفى هل يمكن التعويل على تحول في
الموقف الدولي
نعم وليس على صعيد الحكومات هناك تحول
هائل على الصعيد الدولي على مستوى الشعوب
ثلثي الشعب الالماني حسب اخر الاستطلاعات
مع الفلسطينيين رغم ان حكومتهم لا تاخذ
هذا الموقف
49% من اعضاء الحزب الديمقراطي في
الولايات المتحده الان مع الفلسطينيين على
عكس ما كان عليه الحال لسنوات طويله هناك
تحول كبير على صعيد الشعوب وهذا امر
النوراني ولكن على صعيد الحكم على صعيد
الحكومات انا اريد ان اشدد الان على نقطه
يعني كما قال السيد بكارينج وهذا ما يكرر
الدبلوماسيون باستمرار المصطلحات لها
اهميه كبرى عندما يقال النزاع المشكله
العنف
هذه مساواه بين الطرفين وهذه تغطيه على
الحقيقه الحقيقه الجوهريه هنا في جنين وفي
فلسطين وبشكل عام ان هناك قاتل وشهداء
فلسطينيين ان هناك محتل وشعب تحت الاح ان
هناك مضطهد يستخدم نظام الابرتايد العنصري
وشعب يعاني من نظام التمييز العنصري
يتحدثوا عن حل الدولتين ماذا فعلوا للوصول
الى حل الدولتين قتل حل الدولتين بما قامت
به اسرائيل وهم يتفرجون الولايات المتحده
لو ارادت في ثلاث دقائق تستطيع ان تجبر
نتنياهو على وقف الاستيطان فورا لو ارادت
تستطيع ان تجبره على وقف هذه الهجمات على
الفلسطينيين لكنها ضعيفه امام اسرائيل
وضعيفه امام نتنياهو ثم يلوم الضحيه يلوم
الفلسطينيين لانهم يقاومون لماذا لا
تستخدم نفس المعادن التي تستخدم
هو وافق بجانب من حديثه عما تقول ولكن
يعني لنكسب الوقت معك اريد ان اسالك عن
الوعيد الان من جانب وزراء يمنيين متطرفين
في هذه الحكومه يدعون الى شن عمليه عسكريه
واسعه في الضفه الغربيه ردا على ما حدث
اليوم في جنين كيف يمكن التعامل مع هذا
الامر وهل الحكومه الاسرائيليه على
استعداد فعلا للقيام بذلك
اعتقد ان هذا الخطر قائم وحقيقي خاصه ان
هؤلاء الفاشين سموتر هم من يسيروا بالامور
في اتجاه التصعيد ونتنياهو يقدم لهم
التنازلات الواحده تلو الاخرى والسبب
الثاني ان نتنياهو الذي يشعر بضغط داخلي
نتيجه المعارضه التي تهدد بان تسقط حكومته
ويذهب الى السجن قد يدخل في عمليه تصعيديه
جديده كما فعل قبل فتره بسيطه في غزه
باغتيال الشهداء من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
التصعيد وارد جدا وممكن جدا لذلك المقاومه
يجب ان تبتسم بالحذر وان يكون هناك حذر
وانتباه وتحضير ولكن في نهايه المطاف انا
اقول اي عمليه ستجري لم ولن تكسر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
ولن تكسر اراده الشعب الفلسطينيه كيف يمكن
التحسب لما يجري التهديد به من جانبي
الوزراء المتطرفين في الحكومه ماذا سيفعل
المجتمع الدولي
هناك الكثير من الاشياء التي يمكن القيام
بها ولكن للاسف
الكثير منها قد تم اقتراحه اكثر من مره من
قبل ولا يؤدي الى اي نتيجه او مخرجه ولا
اي ترتيبات من شانها ان تساعد في احقاق
الحق والائتام بحال للمشكله
اذكر البعض منها واولها وقف السيطان طبعا
الذي هو في تمام
بالاضافه الى منع هذا القضيه من ان تزيد
عرقله الوضع وتتحول الى تحد اكبر بعد
من اجل ان يستفيد الجميع من وجود فعلا
دوله ذات سياده
اذا هذا كله بفعل تجربه الطويله في هذا
المجال طبعا
هناك ضروره ملحه وهي ان يبدا الطرفان في
التحاور في النقاش كل من يقترح ذلك يبدو
انه يتم تجاهله حاليا ولكن بدون التواصل
بدون التفاعل بدون تطوير الفهم لن ننجح
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد توماس السفير توماس
السفير الامريكيه السابق في اسرائيل ضيفا
من فرجينيا وشكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
ضيفنا من رام الله
مشاهدينا الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]